[Music]
on this Wednesday night the questions
and the pressure piling on the Prime
Minister about foreign meddling he's not
interested in protecting the safety of
the people serving this country what was
Justin Trudeau warned about and when
Canada's top grocery execs roasted for
their Rising prices and record profits
your company is making one million
dollars a day in excess profits what
Canada's Finance Minister has asked
Supermarket chains to do restoring their
culture and raising their children at
home a lot of our kids were leaving the
jurisdiction one man's tireless mission
to keep indigenous families together and
clocking in why scientists say it's
about time the moon had its own time
zone
Rebel National with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
is no let up and the pressure on the
prime minister to answer questions about
what he knew about allegations of
Chinese interference in Canada's
Democratic process Global News
investigative reporter Sam Cooper has
seen two high-level National Security
reports which suggests senior government
officials were warned about intelligence
showing Chinese government officials
were covertly funneling money to
Canadian political candidates what is
not clear is who saw those reports and
how seriously the warnings were taken
prime minister Justin Trudeau took a lot
of heat about this in Parliament today
Mackenzie gray has our top story tonight
located in the same building as Justin
Trudeau's office the privy council is
tasked with providing advice to the
government and in January 2022 they
issued a bombshell Special Report
alleging the Chinese Consulate in
Toronto facilitated a large clandestine
transfer of funds earmarked for the 2019
federal election Global News reviewed
the privy Council documents which says
the cash from the Chinese Consulate
allegedly went to an elected provincial
government official via a staff member
of a 2019 Federal candidate intelligence
sources say the provincial official is a
current member of the Ontario
legislature the memo was labeled
finalized suggesting it was meant for
senior officials but when asked the
prime minister's office would not say if
Trudeau read it or even knew about the
report oral in question period the Prime
Minister was Under Fire from the
opposition he's not interested in
protecting the safety of the people
serving this country he's interested in
protecting the Liberal Party of Canada
in response Trudeau turned to an old
talking point thus both myself and the
nsia stated last fall we have no
information on any federal candidates
receiving money from China and that
continues to remain the case the global
news did not report the Prime Minister
knew who received money from Beijing or
even that money made it to the
candidates themselves in November 2022
Global News first reported the Prime
Minister was warned China had allegedly
targeted 11 candidates in the 2019
election through a clandestine Network
to fund their campaigns Trudeau's former
National Security adviser believes the
Prime Minister should have read or been
briefed on the contents of the pretty
Council document given the subject
matter and the seriousness of the
allegations and the fact that we are
either just before or in an election
he should have been made aware but one
document the prime minister is aware of
a report published just two months
before the 2019 election from the
National Security and intelligence
Committee of parliamentarians which
warned foreign States would Target
preferred candidates during the
nomination process and if they win the
help keeps coming in the form of
contributions to and support for the
campaigns and their political parties
according to an unredacted version of
that report viewed by Global News global
news previously reported that
intelligence sources alleged current
liberal MP Han dong was aided by the
Chinese Consulate in Toronto during his
nomination meeting in 2019. allegations
dong and the Liberal Party both deny the
instacop report doesn't give examples of
interference in the 2019 vote but it did
for the 2015 and 2018 elections alleging
a group associated with the Chinese
Embassy attempted to hand pick
candidates and certain Chinese
businesses were urged to make political
contributions through Canadian
subsidiaries Donna Mackenzie gray in
Ottawa thank you and you can read Sam
Cooper's latest report which includes
details on those two high-level National
Security reports it's on our website
globalnews.ca
the CEOs of Canada's three largest
grocery chains defended themselves today
at a parliamentary Committee in Ottawa
they are being called to account for why
food prices are so high and their
profits are so high lobla Empire and
Metro earned a combined total of about 2
billion dollars last year and each of
their top bosses took home financial
compensation in the multi-million dollar
range in some cases that compensation
jumped more than 10 percent in 2022
compared to the year before the exact
say consumer criticism about prices and
profits is understandable but inaccurate
our chief political correspondent David
Aiken has been listening to the
committee David what have they been
saying well it's probably no surprise
Donna that it was the leader of the
country's left-leaning National Party
the NDP of course that led the charge
blaming greedy grocery store chains for
sky-high food prices
we have families that are struggling to
buy food for their kids in this country
in a G7 country and they look at you and
they see you making record profits how
can you justify that drug meat saying
and other MPS took their shots Wednesday
at wealthy grocery stores CEOs
conservatives argued that grocery store
chains are taking advantage of farmers
you as the CEOs of major grocery chains
have an oligopy within only five
companies controlling 80 percent of
grocery stores in Canada and you use
this power to nickel and dime farmers
and wholesalers to the tune of hundreds
of thousands of dollars for many this is
understandable but the CEOs well they
politely pushed back on this political
theater arguing that their company's
profits and their own multi-million
dollar bonuses are not the cause of food
prices which have jumped 10 percent in
just the last four months grocery chains
operate with extremely small profit
margins which means we have minimal
influence on inflation
on a customer's 25 grocery basket we
earn just one dollar in profit it is no
Solace to struggling Canadians buying
groceries to know that food inflation is
a global phenomenon driven by higher
commodity and input costs
meanwhile far away from the committee
room on Parliament Hill the country's
Finance Minister was putting those
grocery chain CEOs on notice grocery
CEOs have a responsibility to their
customers
and they have a responsibility to all
Canadians
to work really really hard
with all of us to get inflation down and
to get prices down
now the solutions presented to
politicians who are quite Keen to lower
the food bills for their voters have so
far been pretty meager a grocery store
code of conduct fine-tuning competition
law and even forcing Banks to charge
Grocers lower transaction fees when
consumers pay for food with their credit
card Donna okay David Aiken and Ottawa
thanks there is a bit of relief tonight
for Canadians feeling the pinch of high
interest rates for the first time in
more than a year the Bank of Canada is
keeping its key interest rate right
where it is at 4.5 percent the central
bank has been raising the rate rapidly
from near zero to its highest level
since 2007. today's announcement
suggests inflation is starting to cool
but that could change and lead to Future
rate hikes in the U.S the chair of the
Federal Reserve said yesterday American
interest rates could rise farther and
faster than previously expected in order
to stabilize prices there
now to part two of our series on the
search for solutions to Ontario's
faltering child welfare system the
indigenous organization nagda windaman
is being praised for its innovative
approach it is a Child Protection Agency
which represents seven First Nations
along the north shore of Lake Huron
between Sault Ste Marie and Sudbury
Carolyn Jarvis met the organization's
Visionary leader who has been
unrelenting in his quest to keep
indigenous children in their communities
Dem
it means standing strong bear
when Kerry Francis became the leader of
an indigenous Child Protection Agency in
2017 the Chiefs had a clear directive
about their children
to bring them home
because a lot of our kids were leaving
the jurisdiction there was a big concern
about that I remember that in years past
babies were apprehended straight from
the hospital kids were placed at Great
distance from their families and culture
you need to start building something new
something out of the box what Kerry
built was nug to windaman an
organization that goes beyond Child
Protection offering family supports and
Mental Health Services to keep children
out of care
who's that among the kids who were
immediately returned home Ethan Pocono
and his younger brother so we both said
it's over we don't want to worry about
it no more
Ethan and his brother were placed in
what he says was a brutal group home a
10-hour drive away
still scars me this day still nightmares
for two years he says he experienced
violence and racism you weren't allowed
to talk in your tongue and you weren't
allowed to do any of that stuff we get
mad send you to your room restrain you
when nog dwindermann took over they
found him a home with his uncle
therapy and today a cell phone plan a
bus pass so that help navigating
adulthood and rediscovering his roots
that is why it's not going to Enderman
is there it's for our young children to
be looked after and
keep the circle going strong
okay next category animals for 400.
culture is knocked windowman's
Cornerstone
one is cheese seasons and if you look on
page two
it's like this anishinaabe Moen language
conference how do we say bead Mani do
Menace to give young people a sense of
identity and restore what was lost
six years the demand for nog dewinderman
Services has exploded but that's not the
trend you want to see today there are
twice as many kids in care am I
concerned about that yes we're very
concerned here Carrie explains it's an
indication of trust in a new system and
Decades of trauma it's because of the
residential schools it's because of the
Union day schools it's because of the 60
scoop that's what we're dealing with
today but dealing with the government of
today isn't without friction Kerry
claims the province is shorting them 18
million dollars annually Ontario needs
to wake up
our funding shortfalls are phenomenal
those are true child welfare costs it
was indigenous Service Canada that's
been walking with us and helping us to
fulfill the balance of child welfare
costs the province has nog dewinderman
should manage within its allocated
budget and continue working with the
federal government
coming full circle for nog to windaman
will be returning the oversight of its
children to its seven-member first
Nations
it's in the midst of a five-year plan to
write its own child welfare laws
it was a different way as far as I'm
concerned there's a better way to
provide child welfare services
and so to a love song they dance
birds and Melody a blend of old and new
an Anthem for nogda winderman's March
forward
Carolyn Jarvis Global News Sudbury
[Music]
there is a developing story in Alberta
about an imperial oil tailings Pond that
has been leaking Wastewater for nine
months but the public was only recently
informed it happened last spring at a
site operated by Imperial oil north of
Fort McMurray as Heather urich's West
explains it highlights a wider problem
about how Canada's energy sector is
being monitored and regulated
it's a bird's eye view of a spill that
brought nine months of oil sands
Wastewater leaks to light we take these
leaks very seriously we have land users
in the area that hunt fish and have
Harvest animals that could have been
exposed from these deadly deadly toxins
the Athabasca chipper won first nation
first learned of the spill last month
but Wastewater had actually been seeping
into the surrounding land for some time
according to the Alberta energy
regulator Imperial first reported
industrial Wastewater was seeping from
its Northern Alberta Curl Lake mine site
in May of 2022 among other contaminants
the toxic waste was found to contain
dangerous levels of arsenic a substance
linked to cancer then another 5.3
million liters of Wastewater enough to
fill more than two Olympic-sized
swimming pools was filled in February
because we are small communities small
First Nations living up north is that
why they didn't tell us about the danger
but first members weren't the only ones
kept in the dark the Northwest
Territories is Downstream from Alberta's
oil sands we don't have an agreement
with the industry or the regulator we
have an agreement with the Alberta
Government and the Alberta Government is
the one that's supposed to be providing
this information both the province and
Imperial have expressed regret over how
the news of the leaks was communicated
but the nine months of silence is
Raising questions around what else the
public may not know the tailings ponds
have become huge 1.4 trillion liters of
toxic waste and so there's a lot of
questions about how many other leaks are
happening that we don't know about the
Alberta energy regulator says it
followed all required processes while
Imperial says its cleanup efforts are
well underway not enough for those who
feel they've been kept in the dark as
they call for greater transparency from
the oil sands and its Regulators Heather
urich's West Global News Calgary
[Music]
coming up anger in the streets of
Georgia over a proposed new law
there's widespread outrage in the former
Soviet Republic of Georgia over a
proposed new law that critics say will
push that country towards
authoritarianism
for a second night protesters took to
the streets of the Capitol to Belize
police used water cannon and tear gas
against them the so-called foreign
agents law would require non-government
and media organizations which received
more than 20 percent of their funding
from overseas to register as for an
agent surface Hefty fines similar laws
in Russia have severely suppressed Civil
Society
the U.N Secretary General was in Ukraine
today meeting President Vladimir
zielinski they want an extension to a
deal with Russia that allows Kiev to
export grain through the Black Sea they
say it's critically important to Global
Food security and food prices the
120-day agreement ends on March 18th
I had the risks for women working in
journalism in Afghanistan
[Music]
the United Nations says Afghanistan is
now the world's most repressive country
for women and girls since the Taliban
took over millions of women and girls
have been deprived of their most basic
human rights forbidden from education
work and public spaces essentially
confined to their homes Afghanistan was
never an easy place to be a female
journalist and now it's even harder for
the few who remain tonight we are
sharing their stories journalists facing
death threats intimidation and arrest
shagufa Danish is well aware of this she
spent much of her career as a journalist
in Kabul and now works in our Ottawa
Bureau here is her report
if you turn on the news in Afghanistan
you already see a woman's full face
that's because it's forbidden the
Taliban ordered female anchors to follow
a harsh dress code elham Works under
these brutal conditions journalism was a
dream for me but that dream is in danger
alham is not her real name Global News
is concealing her identity to protect
her career and her life she has been
arrested intimidated and even threatened
with death alhamdi called that time a
Taliban fighter brought her and her
cameraman in for questioning a senior
Taliban officer said this when they
arrived that while you have bring this
issue to here you should kill him on the
street and you should shoot her 19
Afghan journalists have been killed in
the past two years
since the Taliban took over more than 50
percent of Afghan media Outlets have
closed while 95 percent of female
journalists in the country have lost
their jobs the situation is worse than
what we are hearing rubinoi wall helps
relocate women journalists from
Afghanistan to Canada and says those
numbers do not tell the full reality
Canada is a democratic country but when
see them in action they are not doing
much journalists for human rights gets
called from women every day looking for
a way out of Afghanistan until the
Canadian government speeds up the
process to resettle them day one most
will be stuck in hiding although most of
her colleagues have left the country El
homas vowing to remain I'm going to be a
hope and to be the voice of female the
voice of women the voice of have one
journalist a brave voice in a country
where women and the truths are under
attack
Global News
Ottawa
[Music]
timely solution next improving how we
track time on the moon
[Music]
former liberal cabinet minister and
former astronaut Mark garneau is
resigning as a member of parliament the
74 year old made the announcement in the
House of Commons this afternoon and was
met with Applause from both sides of the
aisle garneau was first elected in
Quebec in 2008 he served as Canada's
foreign affairs minister and transport
Minister and before politics garneau was
the first Canadian to fly in space in
1984. from 2001 to 2005 he led the
Canadian space agency
it can be a challenge keeping track of
time zones here on Earth there are six
in Canada alone so imagine trying to
figure out what time it is on the moon
several countries are now planning lunar
missions and the European Space Agency
says the system in place right now is
not good enough is Eric Sorensen
explains their solution is to develop a
new lunar time zone
if it's eight o'clock in Vancouver nine
in Calgary and 11 p.m in Toronto what
time is it on the Moon the Moon sits
above many time zones but why does it
matter it's a distant unpopulated
landscape after all but it won't always
be and liftoff of Artemis one NASA has
started up Moon missions again and now
countries around the world are sending
spacecraft to the moon plus private
companies are seeing big business and
tourism opportunities on the moon the
European Space Agency says it's time the
world agreed on a standard of time for
Moon travel to ensure Global
coordination the Moon is about to become
a very busy place over the next decade
and probably for the rest of its
existence and you know unique and
efficient and safe system in place it's
like the growth of train travel in the
19th century countries needed timetables
for trains Crossing Borders it's why
they came up with 24 basic time zones
around the world more if you count
Newfoundland and Labrador the moon will
become both a destination and a a hub
for space travel a busy lunar Highway
with speeds up to 40 000 kilometers an
hour is dangerous plus time is quicker
on the moon it has to do with the moon's
mass less gravity Einstein all that
stuff it just means clocks gain about 56
microseconds per day on the moon not a
lot but in Moon travel Precision matters
it's just not going to be a big deal for
people but we live in a computerized age
where time is really important in
keeping our time systems set as
accurately as we possibly can scientists
will have to figure out a universal
lunar time keeping system and Nations
will have to agree on it it's taken
about four billion years but it seems
time is of the essence for the moon to
get its own clock Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is this foggy view of
Australia British Columbia we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
foreign